if you listen to Benito Mussolini who
knew a thing or two about fascism
he said that fascism is the merger of
state and corporate powers
now people will deny that and they'll
say that's not exactly what he said but
if you really look into it that's what
he said
milk is an important part of every good
diet
use the best grade of milk Available to
You disease may be contracted through
drinking unsanitary raw milk
[Music]
in 2010 there was a simultaneous rate on
two different locations in California
heavily armed agents stormed into
private properties arresting several U.S
citizens for dealing in a restricted
substance
now drug raids happen quite frequently
in the U.S it's just one of the ways the
authorities keep us free from malicious
and harmful substances
only this wasn't a drug raid
the substance being sold wasn't crack or
crystal meth or even bootleg Hooch
[Music]
it was milk
this is an example of just how
heavy-handed the government is in
routing out disfavored parties in this
case the government operates on a public
interest argument that raw milk is
inherently unsafe it is a breeding
ground for bacteria and because it is
not pasteurized the argument is it
carries with it an enormous increased
risk for consumers such that it
shouldn't be available this is the
position of the Food and Drug
Administration and the government cracks
down on this one segment and they do so
with Brute Force sending in
Stormtroopers essentially and shutting
down the milk plant in its entirety and
confiscating all of the milk regardless
of whether it's contaminated or not
the FDA raided this Organic Market in
order to keep us safe from the dangers
of unpasteurized milk
buying and selling unpasteurized milk
that is
they have no problem with you drinking
raw milk if say you find a stray cow on
the way home and decide to milk it
yourself
but a reputable farmer trying to sell
some to willing customers that's a big
No-No
although this Organic Market was a club
with each member having signed a waiver
acknowledging the potential risk of
drinking raw milk this was not good
enough for the FDA
and these people not realize that raw
milk is a gateway food what next people
eating cheese knocking back raw oysters
Sushi or heaven forbid eggs
luckily the FDA was there to step in and
save these adults at gunpoint from the
dangers of raw milk
the reason why pasteurized milk doesn't
come under this scrutiny and the reason
why raw milk as opposed to cheese eggs
raw oysters Sushi why they don't come
under the same FDA scrutiny is that the
major milk manufacturers are a principal
Lobby within the FDA they have very
small profit margins per unit and so if
in Whole Foods and other places there
are significant numbers of consumers who
come in to buy raw milk products it is a
significant economic effect on the large
milk processors
the California milk raids were not an
isolated event
over the past few years there have been
raids all across the U.S to crack down
on the sale of many organic products but
despite any claims of safety concerns or
risk one thing is clear the actions of
the Regulatory Agencies and by extension
the politicians that manage them are not
motivated by any notion of public good
they're motivated by the desire to stay
in power
that takes money
the problem with the U.S political
system is that it revolves around money
and so immediately that sets off this
dichotomy of those who can afford to
play in the system and those who can't
to run for office you need one and a
half million dollars you need about 11
million dollars to run for the Senate so
if you don't have money where do you go
you go to the people who have a hand
stretched out with money
ready to fund your campaign but they're
going to want something in return
because of course they're not giving
this money for charitable reasons
it very clearly advantages big
businesses because they have more
capacity to devote resources to
influence buying
political influence has become just
another Arsenal in the marketing toolbox
of large companies only instead of
promoting themselves they use this
influence to suppress the competition
and the key to it all are lobbyists
people think that we live in a free
market society and we don't
big government and big business are way
too closely aligned today especially in
the United States and uh this you know
is because of lobbying basically we have
uh cronyism we don't have capitalism in
the United States especially when it
comes to the military and then Big
Medicine big food like Monsanto you know
with all the GMOs and stuff most people
don't want it but yet it's being forced
on us because Monsanto has such leverage
in Congress through all the lobbying of
the food industry
[Music]
his lobbying well simply lobbying is the
act of influencing decisions made by
legislators and Regulatory Agencies you
know the guys who make the rules and the
people who exert this influence are
called lobbyists well-connected
professionals with slick suits Slicker
tongues
lobbyists tend to be experts in the
fields they Lobby for they advise
lawmakers on how to make sure Americans
are getting the most benefit from the
laws they pass while also reducing
potential harm
it's a good idea why wouldn't you want
an expert's advice
here's where things get screwy sometimes
the lawmakers decide the cash is greener
on the other side so they become
lobbyists themselves they leave
government and join a private company
taking their connections and influence
with them
this phenomenon is called the revolving
door people going from regulating an
industry to working in that same
industry and sometimes back and forth
multiple times
corporations love having such powerful
people on their payroll so they do
everything they can to lure them over
and for their part The Regulators help
out by making a few Choice laws to
benefit their future employers
and with the spin of the door comes a
host of new laws that benefit some
companies hinder others but business
keeps rolling and in the end no one
really gets hurt except of course the
people
you'll see members of Congress who will
take on issues defending one particular
special interest and then go out to work
for that special interest after they
leave and the same is true of all
government agencies in fact that's
considered the normal way to do business
in Washington
big government and big business
essentially are the same are they not
what's the difference between a
corporation
and the government agency when the
corporation buys the politicians with
campaign donations and the politicians
do as they're told in passing laws that
the corporation would have passed had
the corporation been the government
sadly this phenomenon is all too common
today and it's not specific to just one
industry rather it seems that many of
the agencies would have the power to
influence our daily lives are corrupted
by the revolving door
[Music]
when you have delegated power to
committees and government officials and
agencies to regulate the economy it
always leads to corruption it's too
tempting for people not to use that
power for their own personal agendas and
the revolving door is merely proof of
the fact that when you give government
and its agencies the power to regulate
commerce it always always will lead to
corruption
nine tenths of all federal law
is not the product of those we elect but
rather the product of the unelected
heads of these bureaucratic agencies so
we do not have a limited federal
republic in the United States what we
have instead is an unlimited
bureaucratic oligarchy in which these
bureaucratic agencies operate largely
without any accountability
this isn't a representative form of
government they only represent the most
powerful the people are getting the most
amount of money
the corporations the multinationals have
taken over
whether it's agriculture whether it's
broadcasting whether it's
pharmaceutical whether it's retail you
name the field a few control it all
wrong
laws and regulations are essential to
any modern society there are some
activities that need to be controlled or
prevented for the sake of the common
good which side of the road you can
drive
whether a five-year-old should be able
to buy a bottle of Jack
how many return trips you can make to a
buffet in a single sitting
okay maybe scratch that last one but you
get the idea
but with so much collusion between
regulators and the industries they
regulate the laws governing our daily
lives are becoming excessive unnecessary
and often downright nonsensical
keeping the public safe and free is no
longer the primary goal for a number of
our lawmakers
there is little done by the federal
government that is not influenced by a
choice to favor one special interest
over another
a lot of regulations are adopted with a
public interest veneer
but underneath they're the product of
negotiation between industry leaders and
government to create a barrier to entry
and many of these actions taken have
enormous Economic Consequences both
eliminating competition to a company and
enhancing their economic status
this relationship between big business
and government agencies not only affects
their competition in the economy but all
of us in our day-to-day lives
what you want to do in an economy is you
want to produce the products and
services that are in greatest demand and
no one knows that except the market but
when politicians come in and they
substitute their own judgment
generally they're not even trying to out
guess the market and figure out what's
best for us they're generally just
trying to give an advantage to one
particular individual or group of
individuals at the expense of another
and so there are clear winners and
losers whoever's on the receiving end of
a subsidy or government expenditure
versus who's getting regulated or taxed
but regardless of the individual winners
and losers collectively we lose
because wealth is destroyed resources
are allocated in a less than optimal way
can pay enough money you can make sure
that you win on whatever issue you are
concerned about maybe it's stopping
legislation maybe it's to get something
passed but ultimately you're looking to
shape
policy and that policy has real impact
in our daily lives it shapes what kinds
of products we can buy at the store it
shapes how safe those products are it
shapes what we are allowed to know about
those products
the fda's war against unpasteurized milk
is just one example of the way large
food producers are using their
connections in Washington to limit our
choices at the grocery store while
increasing their own profits but it is
by no means the only example
big government is in a collusion with
big agriculture
there were never any scientific studies
that determined that GMO food is
equivalent to conventionally grown food
the Food and Drug Administration the
United States said well
Monsanto has vouched for the safety of
GMO food and Monsanto said the FDA has
certified it is safe
that's big business and big government
together
foreign
but some small independent Farms are
choosing not to use patented GMO crops
or work for larger agribusiness concerns
some just want to supply their local
area with nutritious Farm Fresh Food
one such farmer is Joel salatu
he runs his farm based on an Innovative
and radical new technique which he calls
letting his animals out to pasture
sounds crazy but maybe he's on to
something
we have a very different set of of
production and processing criteria first
of all our animals move they're not in
great big confinement animal feeding
operations our animals don't do drugs
we don't vaccinate we don't medicate and
we run our farm on the closed carbon
cycle as opposed to buying in chemical
fertilizer from outside so you know the
localization the carbon cycle animals
move around the lack of pharmaceuticals
all of that is 180 degrees different
than today's industrial Global
petroleum-based Food system
it turns out there is a healthy market
for a traditionally farmed meat and
produce so why are there so few
independent Farms operating around the
country
the story of Chicago and its great
Stockyard symbolized the amazing
economic Revolution that was underway on
the farms machines and improved
techniques of Agriculture began to
produce an abundance of food for
consumption both at home and abroad the
new world of mass production required
increasing concentrations of capital
pooling the Investments of many people
the corporation became the means to
starting vast new Enterprises
the globalization and corporatization of
everything is gradually
making it more and more difficult for
independent
Farmers independent people in the food
system to Market to their neighbors to
friends to family to whatever
and you do think
every day about
what bureaucrat is going to invade my
life today
every single time the government
penetrates the marketplace
it always favors the biggest players
because they're the ones that are able
to buy favors to Curry concessionary
privileges in a regulatory climate and
so I know that many of the consumer
advocacy folks mean well when they say
we need more oversight we need more
regulations for you know this bad thing
that happened over here
what they don't realize is that by the
time that regulation actually gets
enacted
and and filters down to the you know to
the farm level
it always always always
hurt small producers and helps the large
producers
it's the revolving door don't eat
healthy only eat crap
a few companies control everything
there's only a small group of
agribusiness companies that control the
entire food production they're putting
everybody out of business they don't
want any competition
the small farmer is always a threat
if 50 million people in the United
States decide on their own that they
would prefer to buy their produce
from small farmers or at farmers markets
because they think it's healthier
that's a defection out of the system
government doesn't want that and
Monsanto certainly doesn't want it nor
do any of the big agribusiness companies
want it so better to do everything
possible to wipe out the small farmer in
America
make them go bankrupt make them sell his
land which is then taken over by some
larger agricultural
entity
until eventually the entire food chain
is controlled by big corporations and
big government
the regulations forced upon small
independent Farms like Joel's have
created a hurdle which limits the size
and scope of his operation
and whether these regulations are well
intentioned or imposed just to give an
unfair advantage to the big guys the end
result is that many of the products Joel
would like to sell have been deemed
illegal
the things that we would like to do from
curing meat to selling raw milk for
example you know we would love to sell
raw milk and we have customers who love
to get raw milk but it's illegal
we just had a health department
inspector they told us that our
slaughtering shed for the poultry was
illegal and wanted to close us down and
their contention was that if it's
actually open to the air it's inherently
unsanitary
[Music]
what's fascinating is a feed lot
in deplorable conditions with no
trespassing signs
gets away with almost anything but
because we are extremely transparent
Outdoors you know out here it makes us
vulnerable to the anthropomorphism of
ignorant people
you're probably thinking that these
agricultural regulations are meaningless
to you if these regulations are limiting
your choices how come you can walk down
any aisle in the supermarket and find
dozens of different brands and hundreds
of different foods I mean how much
Choice do we really need
average person walks into the
supermarket right and they see all this
stuff on the shelves they say what do
you mean I don't have choice I can get
count chocula breakfast cereal Fruit
Loops Cracker Jacks whatever okay I can
get potato chips from 10 different
companies you know what do you mean I
don't have choice
and so it's a hard sell because people
have a hard time understanding what they
can't get
you know what you can't get is raw milk
what you can't get is backyard
slaughtered poultry that never went
through a great big processing plant
there's a tremendous amount of artisanal
Heritage type food that is unavailable
now because it has been criminalized and
outlawed
in the end it comes down to risk some
things like raw milk are just too risky
to let out to the public
after all contaminated raw milk could
theoretically be as harmful as poison
[Music]
actual poison on the other hand is
apparently fine
if you want to talk about risk isn't it
fascinating that the very entity that
gave us DDT that gave us a mad cow
that gave us cloning that gave us GMOs
these are very risky things I mean
whether or not you believe in them or
not you have to appreciate those are all
very high risk things
and they are the ones that we say I want
to put my faith in you for my food
I think people participate in Risky
behavior all the time you know I think
if you're feeding your kids pasteurized
milk Cocoa Puffs count chocula cereal
and Fruit Loops that's risky Behavior
but the government has decided that
that's not risky Behavior
what's risky behavior is drinking a
glass of raw milk
when it comes down to it not being able
to get raw milk isn't that big a deal I
mean who needs raw milk when you can get
deep fried mozzarella sticks or tasty
tasty chicken fingers
after all food is food right
I think it's important to realize that
in 1979 when the first USDA food pyramid
came out you know with grains on the
bottom
that was the beginning of the Obesity in
type 2 epidemic because it put
carbohydrates on the bottom
and uh and you know it's it's quite a
profound reality that America today
would be far far healthier if the
government had never told us what to eat
so maybe you overdo it slightly on the
saturated fats and imitation cheese who
cares we've got access to the best drugs
in the world
whether you have a resting heart rate of
116. that third cheeseburger has you
sweating like Shaq at the line or you're
just feeling queasy from all the drugs
you're taking there are drugs out there
to help you
and we can all agree if there is one
area where we want strict regulations
it's Pharmaceuticals after all no one
wants unsafe medicine getting out to the
public
there are of course several drugs many
drugs that are helpful but what concerns
me is that a significant minority
significant minority of drugs that have
been approved by FDA have been approved
over the fda's own medical reviewers
objections on safety grounds and many
many unsafe drugs have been admitted
into the marketplace that actually cause
death liver failure kidney failure heart
attacks these drugs are on the market
many of them still and are approved
yearly
it is thanks to such rigorous quality
control by the FDA that a drug like
vioxx which caused over a hundred
thousand heart attacks and tens of
thousands of deaths was swiftly pulled
from the market
after only five years and 2.5 billion in
profit for the pharmaceutical giant Merc
when an FDA commissioner knowingly
approves an unsafe drug like vioxx and
keeps it on the market even though
they're 140 000 heart attacks blacks and
sixty thousand deaths from it and still
stands in defense of that company Merck
there's something wrong here there's
something dreadfully wrong why can't
that person be held accountable and yet
they get away with it not only they get
away with it but in the case of the
commissioner who did that Lester
Crawford he ends up being employed by a
company called policy directions Inc at
a very high capacity and that company
represents murder
[Music]
oh
foreign
was just a one-off event there are a
whole host of helpful drugs in the
marketplace and the FDA shouldn't be
scrutinized for one little slip up I
mean it's not like this is happening
regularly
the FDA says that all of these
pharmaceutical drugs that are
everywhere in America
they're safe and effective that's how
they get out into doctors offices and
drugstores and that's why people ingest
them well
106 000 people every year in the United
States are killed by FDA approved
pharmaceutical drugs the FDA admits this
on their own website but they say
nothing about taking responsibility for
it
it's just another medical fact to them
huh over a hundred thousand deaths from
prescription drugs every year
you'd think with all the stringent
testing the FDA does before it lets it
drug out onto the market they detect
some of these life-threatening side
effects
these are the bottles which finally will
find their way to doctors offices and
Clinics all over the country even as
they reach the end of the production
line other tests are in progress and
samples are sent to the government the
manufacturer's protocol is first
reviewed
then subjected to a whole battery of
complex scientific tests
the fda's whole system of drug review is
bogus it's designed to protect and
Advance the interests of the drug
industry a lot of people don't realize
this but FDA never tests the drugs it
approves FDA does no independent testing
at all
it relies entirely on the testing done
by the drug Advocate the proponent of
the drug application that has a
self-interest and a conflict of interest
that party is looked to for all of the
drug testing
they do their own testing
so the FDA does no independent testing
of the drugs that approves but with so
many new drugs being manufactured can
you blame them for outsourcing the
testing to the drug companies themselves
after all if you can't trust a
multi-billion dollar pharmaceutical
conglomerate who can you trust
there have been multiple instances of
corruption in this process where
negative information has been kept away
from the FDA so that the FDA will
approve a drug
in fact sanofi aventis with its drug key
Tech relied principally on a clinical
trial that fda's medical reviewers who
are sharp on the case discovered didn't
even happen
they made it up
and there were FBI investigations and
prosecutions
but what did the FDA do the the medical
reviewers said that the commissioner gee
they relied on a fraud for this
application we should deny it but the
FDA commissioner granted it he put key
Tech into the market
so you see it's that degree of influence
and Corruption that makes it impossible
for the American people to be protected
with drugs being approved by the FDA
despite the objection of their own
medical reviewers there can be little
doubt the revolving door is Alive and
Well in the pharmaceutical industry
and just in case you do have some tiny
shred of Doubt remaining consider the
case of Billy tazen
you may want to have some anti-nausea
pills on standby
[Music]
Congressman Billy tazen who is the head
of the Energy and Commerce Committee in
the house he was the man assigned the
task of ensuring that a provision would
be put into the law that would prevent
the entire government from negotiating
down the per unit price of drugs
required to be acquired under Medicare
Part D
based on volume
so in other words they're forced to pay
whatever price the drug industry sets
per unit for the drugs purchased under
Medicare Part D and that is something
that could enable the drug industry at
its will to bring the nation to its
knees financially and so it is that this
provision was put into the law in the
Bush Administration tazen left the the
government left his position in Congress
became the head of the pharmaceutical
research and manufacturers Association
and made the highest salary they had
ever then paid to that date 2.5 million
a year
as a compliment for his selling out the
nation to protect the drug industry
so while the government may be choosing
often poorly which Food and Drugs they
think are safe for us to have at least
they aren't trying to force any of them
on you
except perhaps for vaccines
George Lambert is a representative of
the New Hampshire state house and he is
a leading proponent for vaccination
choice in his state
when I got to the State House somebody
asked me if I would work on a bill for
vaccination Choice the more research I
did the more I found out that in the
risk of an epidemic they can go out and
vaccinate everyone without choice
[Music]
to say that vaccines are compulsory
which in the U.S
is the struggle right now
every state has their own
exemptions
that parents can claim
but now the push is on to say that we're
going to force you to get vaccinated
whether you like it or not you don't
have the freedom to decide
if we talk about medical safety and
freedom everybody should have the choice
as of what medical procedures they want
you can get a medical exclusion you can
get a religious exclusion but you can't
get a conscientious exclusion we had an
issue in New Hampshire
a couple years ago where there were some
injections that were contaminated that
might actually contain meningitis but if
you're required to get a vaccination or
an injection how do you know the
injection isn't contaminated but if you
want your children to go to school or
participate in any of these other
activities the government says you
either do this or you're excluded that's
a problem because when the news says
there's something that puts your life at
risk you should be able to make an
educated decision
[Music]
that's what Freedom really comes down to
in the end the freedom to decide for
good or bad how you want to live and
that freedom should not be overruled by
the government except in the most
extreme cases or to keep us safe from
the most diabolical of threats
weed grass ganja joint doobie do chronic
Ace Lobo Loco Love Boat but Buddha blunt
pot pet bin Shiva Chiba 420 and hashish
or hash for short no matter what you
call it no matter what hip Street lift
it's referred or reapered to buy it all
comes from the same stash it's all
marijuana
foreign
one of the most dangerous drugs known to
mankind responsible for almost as many
deaths per year as asteroids or shark
attacks it can cause an otherwise
healthy adult to giggle or get a bit
hungry
thankfully the brave men and women from
numerous agencies have been waging a
tireless and expensive war against this
dangerous plant for decades
the War on Drugs is a war on the people
it's a war to fight for the
pharmaceutical industry so they could
sell their psychotropic drugs I mean
Jesus how many people
that I hear horror stories from their
children whacked out on Vicodin oh
that's a beaut
yeah how about a little Oxycontin you
know to make you happy feel some pain
this will get rid of it but don't get
high man no weed it's gonna kill you you
saw a Reefer Madness
[Music]
Reefer Madness is a celebrated PSA film
produced for the U.S government known
for its even-handed and unbiased
approach to subject of marijuana which
it claims is worse than heroin it saved
Generations from the dangers of
marijuana even a single puff Mary Jane
can make you dance like a fool laugh
uncontrollably
[Laughter]
or violently murder your friends
how embarrassing
normal is a non-profit organization
whose aim is to legalize cannabis
throughout the United States
there are eight hundred thousand people
a year arrested in the United States on
marijuana charges 90 percent for
possession only
so over a 40-year period now that's
roughly 27 million people have been
arrested on marijuana charges so it's
created a huge Universe of people who
have been effectively screwed by the
government
when we sue the DEA in the classic case
normal versus DEA the judge ruled in
1988 in his final decision that
marijuana quote is the safest
therapeutic substance known to man
um that's a pretty strong indictment
against the rest of the drugs
so the courts acknowledge that marijuana
is the most therapeutic substance known
to man
but since as early as the 1930s
marijuana has been the subject of
countless heavy-handed and fallacious
propaganda
long-term use of marijuana can lead to a
psychological dependency soon you'll be
taking all sorts of measures to get your
picks
people will start calling you names like
pothead or Smokey mcfong water losing
all motivation it's likely that you'll
drop out of school
take a sudden liking to sitar music and
maybe even get felt up by a cop or two
marijuana has been propagandized by the
United States government and its
surrogates at the state level
for at least 75 years
there are 1200 partnership for drug-free
America ads and 85 to 90 percent of
those ads have been against marijuana
and the name alone Drug Free America
deserves nothing but pure laughter drug
hyphen free America this is the most
drug adult Society in human history
and The Drug Free America Association
was originally founded by the Alcohol
Tobacco and pharmaceutical companies
which last I checked their business
model is Distributing drugs
personal feelings about marijuana aside
there is no denying the fact that
criminalization of the substance Bears
little parity with other substances in
the same area such as alcohol or tobacco
but with all the millions being spent on
preventing its use and Prosecuting
individuals who use it
who stands to gain
there are entities out there that
strongly Lobby for the status quo to
stay in place
law enforcement
the very government agencies born of the
prohibition like the partnership for
Drug Free America the Dare program the
DEA the drug czar's office they will
always oppose legalization
three would be the Alcohol Tobacco
pharmaceutical companies that play both
ends of the middle
they try to start things like the
partnership for drug-free America but
pretty clearly don't want to really have
a Drug Free America
the fourth entity are companies that are
able to make money off of the
prohibition and that would be private
prisons drug testing companies this is
probably the most naked of our
opposition because if you get caught
with marijuana
you can either choose the route of
prosecution and potential conviction and
then going to jail or you go to rehab
well even the director of normal if I
got caught by police with a small amount
of marijuana if I'm given a trace
between going to jail and going to rehab
I'm going to pick rehab and so 80 of
their clientele are effectively pushed
in the door by the government so this is
an incestuous relationship that has been
set up between the drug rehabilitation
profiteers and the government that
brings their clients right to their door
and we the taxpayers
pay for the rehabilitation
now in the language the addicts use
among themselves they never say to each
other let's smoke a marijuana cigarette
they say let's turn on or let's blast a
joint
as with drinking raw milk smoking a
marijuana cigarette carries with it
obvious health risks but whether you
want to blast a j or buy an outdoor
slaughtered chicken from your local
farmer powerful lobbying groups have
colluded with regulatory agencies to
limit your freedom of choice
when the government violently kicks down
your door and comes onto your property
with guns drawn trying to get you to
stop engaged in a certain Behavior
that's harming nobody else that is a
social injustice
I personally think of cannabis as just a
metaphor for Freedom
um I think of it almost purely at this
point now as a discussion over personal
freedom and how much can the government
intervene in your life and intervene
violently with guns drawn
okay we've talked a lot about food and
medicine and Lobo but enough of that
hippie talk everyone knows the world
revolves around one thing and one thing
only
milk
I mean money
but similar to Independent Farmers small
firms in the financial sector also face
heavy regulations which benefit the
large players
I act in the Securities industry and
there's all sorts of rules and
regulations that I have to abide by
the vast majority of it doesn't protect
my customers the individual investor and
that's not why I believe it's there
that's the excuse that the politicians
give the voters but the real reason is
because there are very large Banks and
brokerage firms that don't like small
firms like mine competing with them and
so they want to tie us up in red tape
see they can afford to pay for the
regulations it's the small firms that
can't but they didn't do it to help the
investor they did it to help the big
brokerage firms that wanted protection
from competition and and so that's what
happens but of course the revolving door
is
when these guys leave Washington they
get cushy jobs at the companies they
used to regulate and in fact they go
back and forth they go from the industry
to the government back to the industry
to the government and what they're
really doing is they're peddling their
influence
they go to Washington to to get clout to
get influence to make friends and then
they sell the influence to the highest
bidder uh when they leave
sadly the finance industry may be the
best illustration of the intertwining of
government and big business
for example the current Secretary of the
Treasury Jacob Liu was reportedly given
a 950
000 bonus by his former employer
Citigroup just for taking a job at the
treasury
[Music]
if you want to see the proof of fascism
all you have to do is look at four
simple words
too big to fail
the merger of state and corporate powers
when America had a financial crisis in
the whole game changed
[Music]
the bags got in trouble they bring out
Henry Paulson
the U.S treasury secretary former CEO of
the Goldman Sachs gang and since we have
to bail out the banks they're too big to
fail
[Music]
foreign
the subprime mortgage crisis of 2008 was
the biggest economic crash since the
Great Depression
in the midst of the crisis the financial
media demanded stricter regulations on
the financial industry
Economist Peter Schiff who predicted the
crisis years in advance believes that
Not only was Wall Street to blame but
more importantly it was The Regulators
colluding with the financial industry
who were responsible for the crisis
while The Regulators caused the crisis
it was the regulation that created the
problem
I was talking about the coming housing
crisis in 2002 three four five six and I
was pointing out exactly how the
government and the FED were creating the
problem so the people that now said we
didn't have enough regulation where were
they back then why didn't they say we
needed more regulation in 2004 or 2005.
the fact of the matter is it was the
regulations that were in place that
caused the problem
[Music]
the Federal Reserve in order to
stimulate the economy brought interest
rates down to one percent
and what that did is it enabled people
to borrow money more cheaply to buy
houses in the meantime too the
government was also guaranteeing the
mortgages and this was the real problem
the way the market regulates Banks is
that individuals want a safe place for
their money and so they will shop around
for a safe place therefore Market
pressures forced the banks to do prudent
things to attract deposits but once the
government comes in and says your money
is safe no matter what
now the customer doesn't value safety
anymore because the government is
guaranteed it but the problem with the
government regulation is it's
ineffective and it ends up being
politicized because if you remember
during the housing days as lending
standards kept being lowered and lowered
and lowered it was the government that
was leading the charge to lower
standards because the voters wanted to
buy more houses because housing was
thought of as a way to get rich and the
only obstacle was the down payment the
credit score and so it was the
government that was pressuring Banks hey
forget about credit scores lower those
down payments so the banks are risky the
mortgages are risky nobody cares about
anything because the government's trying
to make everything good the government's
trying to say don't worry about risk
because if you fail we're there to catch
you we're there to prop you up and then
when it doesn't work capitalism gets a
bad name as if any of this has anything
to do with capitalism
skipping ahead to 2011 we find the story
of MF Global a Commodities brokerage
firm headed by former Senator turned
governor of New Jersey John Corzine
it wasn't a pleasant return to Capitol
Hill for former Senator John Corzine he
was subpoenaed to tell lawmakers how the
company he headed MF Global collapsed
and what happened to 1.2 billion dollars
of customers money I simply do not know
where the money is or why the accounts
have not been reconciled today
don't you hate it when you can't find
your keys your phone or a billion
dollars of other people's money it's so
frustrating
but as uncomfortable as Corazon may have
been sitting there and pretending to
feel bad others felt a little more mf'd
by the situation
I got burned by the MF Global Scandal
that's when John Corzine the former
Governor Democratic governor of New
Jersey and former senator of New Jersey
and form the head of the Goldman Sachs
gang
after he did a stint with those he was
the head of NF Global yeah Ms perfect
MF Global went into my segregated
account and stole my money
six figures and I work hard for my money
I wasn't speculating in the markets he
went in and stole my money
while investigating how this money was
stolen out of his account without the
financial Regulators intervening Mr
celente's investigations found The
Tell-Tale squeak of the revolving door
the cftc is the agency which regulates
brokerage firms like MF global
at the time of the MF robbery the cftc
was headed by one Gary Gensler close
colleague of corzines
[Music]
Gary's never once let his team forget
what this is all about
the American people do you know what the
Commodities future trading commission
did to John causeline
after robbing me and thousands
nothing
nothing Gary Gensler was his Lieutenant
at Goldman Sachs and he's the head of
the Commodities future trading
Commission
you wanted to I mean to say that the fox
is watching the chicken coop is stupid
that's it's worse than that
[Music]
the MF Global collapse is an example of
the alliance between regulators and big
business in the financial industry
but a more troubling phenomenon called a
Balin was recently seen in Cyprus
even in my diarist predictions in this
Parliament over the years about the way
the EU bosses were behaving never did I
think that they would in a completely
unprecedented manner resort to stealing
money from People's Bank account
recently in Cyprus the banks had been
irresponsible and it was the public all
of the depositors that paid the price
and they called it a bail in to make it
uh sound different from a bailout
what happened was many of the banks in
Cyprus bought a lot of Greek government
debt and as you know over the last few
years Greek government debt has all but
collapsed so that made these Cypress
Banks all but insolvent and they went
just like oh is the big Banks went with
the government and said hey we're broke
can you help us out and steal money for
us and that's what they did they just
said take 50 percent of anyone over a
hundred thousand dollars take 50 percent
of all their money just take it
just the term bail in is a lie this is
something that is a marketing tool to
basically uh cover up a theft
a bailout the whip up currency and they
give it to the banks and then the public
eventually pays for that through a tax
called inflation because there's now
more currency in existence a bail in
they skip the part of creating currency
and they just take it from the
depositors but basically the banks win
at the Publix expense either way
but that was Cyprus not the US there's
just no way the citizens of North
America would allow something as
underhanded as a bail in
Canada actually put in their 2013 budget
a Balian Clause the exact same thing
they said if the Canadian banks have
problems that they can just take it from
Canadian citizens the U.S has been
talking about it as well the governments
allow these Banks to do these kind of
things
Cyprus was the model to see if they
could get away with it they got away
with it and uh so now it's proven
successful so it is a solution they can
use in the future
in hindsight it seems obvious that the
financial sector would be Rife with
corruption and back dealing
Finance education the prison system the
military industrial complex almost every
industry in which there is money to be
made has been affected by the revolving
door
even relatively new agencies are subject
to its spin if you need proof try to
take some nail clippers onto a domestic
flight
when you go to the airport the TSA
agents you know want to go out and they
want to invade your privacy they want to
look through your bags they want to do
all of this stuff and you don't have the
option to say no once you get in line
you can't get out now what is the point
of the entire TSA system it's security
theater it's to make people feel scared
not to make people feel safe because the
more they can actually make people feel
scared the more they can actually take a
little bit of their rights away all the
time and constantly remind them that
they need the government to make sure
that their safety is well taken care of
the body scanners that stop you from
taking dangerous objects like bottles of
water onto planes were installed due to
TSA regulations
as head of the Department of Homeland
Security Michael chertoff required every
airport in the country have those
scanners installed for our safety of
course
this technology allows us to detect any
item concealed on a person's body
including molded plastic hidden under
clothing
scanners themselves are built and
installed by a company called rapidscan
can you guess who worked as a consultant
for rapidscan after leaving Homeland
Security
oh yeah I remember let me see
jerk off jerkloof some somebody jerk off
chair cloth he was the head of the
homeland security right after the
Underpants bomber right after that
happened
whatever his name is he appeared on all
the national media
we have to get them x-ray machines in
there
rapist scam
a rapid scan somebody's scam that's the
name of the company yeah with the
x-rayed they x-rayed it
oh
son of a gun
wow
jerk off
is a consultant for that company after
he left Homeland Security
okay let's get this straight GMOs safe
raw milk unsafe preparing poultry in the
open air is unsanitary but drugs that
cause heart attacks are fine blasting a
joint will make you want to kill
getting X-rayed at the airport is vital
to National Security and stealing from
your customers is okay provided you do
it a billion dollars at a time
[Music]
with regulatory agencies so deeply
entangled with big business it's almost
impossible to know whether the rules we
live by are therefore our safety or
someone else's Financial benefit
whatever the reason the end result is
our lives are now so heavily manipulated
by the desires of others our choices are
becoming more and more limited
that's what government regulation is all
about it's all about limiting your
choices
the government wants to make those
choices for you they want to take away
your freedom to choose the choices that
you make the types of food that you eat
right all of this is determined for you
by the government and why can't we make
choices right that's what freedom is
about
the politicians think that hey it's
important that we all vote they can
trust us to vote but they can't trust us
to make these basic decisions about
whether we should buy a house or whether
we should rent their house or should we
use this broker or that broke or should
I put on my seat belt or should I wear a
helmet or should I smoke cigarettes or
you know all these choices need to be
made by the government but somehow we're
smart enough to vote but we're done
we're too dumb to do just about anything
else
this over regulation has implications
other than just limiting our choices
by giving government agencies the
authority to regulate Our Lives even in
the name of protection it has led to an
expansion of government power at the
expense of individual freedoms
what's the old saying give them an inch
and they'll take your money life and
favorite dairy products something like
that
the more laws there are the more rules
and regulations there are the more taxes
there are the less Freedom you have I
mean that's what freedom is it's freedom
from government
so when people are free it means that
they do what they want they don't have
to do what the government tells them
[Music]
career bureaucrats are usually dedicated
pro-regulatory people they are fans of
state paternalism of government making
individual choices and the result of
that is to really deprive individuals of
sovereignty
it makes individuals mere functionaries
of the state rather than people who can
pursue their own self-interest and enjoy
the benefits and blessings of liberty
[Music]
to who owns me who owns the individual
you can't have a system
that denies choice
trying to protect us from the risk of
bad choice
and preserve the freedom
to make good choices that's the problem
you can't have it both ways Freedom
requires risk
should I wear a seatbelt
is this Bank a safe place to keep my
money
do I need insurance
we're all so busy with our daily lives
that making important decisions can
become overwhelmingly daunting
a lot of people prefer the freedom from
making choices even if it means the
choices being made for them aren't the
best
the idea that government should make our
choices for us is one that a lot of
people prefer rather than to make their
own choices
but once the point is reached like in
the former Soviet Union
when choices are Made for You by the
government to such an extent
that it destroys the economy that it
destroys free agency that it renders
everyone a servant
and the state a master
then at some point individuals come in
large numbers to the conclusion that
they're not getting what they were
promised
that they are over taxed they're over
regulated that their choices are limited
that paternalism is disgusting it's
caused me heartache and I'm going to
reject it I want my freedom
until that point is reached most people
will be content with their comfortable
lives and the choices still available to
them
the hard-working people don't have time
to watch or hear what's going on they're
working 24 7 they're trying to make ends
meet
so
what does America watch
hey you know Kim Kardashian is pregnant
she's going to have the kid real soon
the media makes sure that we don't dwell
very long on any really serious issue
we've all seen the phenomenon where
there's something very serious that
comes up involving the serious aspects
of what's going on in the world and it
gets on the news for a very brief period
of time and all of a sudden now that's
been switched off and we're soon
distracted with soapbox operas and
dancing with the stars and all kinds of
things that are entertaining and I'm not
saying anything against them but it's
not as serious as the lack of
everybody's Freedom through a new
Amendment to the Patriot Act for example
the media may try their best to give us
a fair and balanced opinion of world
events but there are now other avenues
available for those seeking unfiltered
news
the way that the net and the web were
built involves a lot of decentralization
it moves power into the hands of of the
people sending and receiving messages as
opposed to the people uh in the middle
that are handing them off and that is a
scary Prospect for uh entrenched
stakeholders
the alternative media other than the the
corporate media that is so rigidly
controlled
is a threat
the internet is certainly a threat
Because the Internet gives almost anyone
access to the world so now are we
surprised when the political figures who
don't like that are constantly worried
about how can we stop this well the
formula has been tried and trued it
always worked just tell the people that
there's a threat out there that only the
government can control I mean there's a
threat of child pornography or crime or
terrorism or cyber terrorism or
something we have to control the
internet for your good folks otherwise
you're going to have a big problem
that's why they're working around the
clock to try and scare people into into
thinking that the internet must be
controlled by our fine trustworthy
political figures they want to be the
ones that control the internet and tell
the world what is proper and what is
improper
if you look at the history of
communications media people said with
cable television will finally be free of
centralization and with the telegram
will finally be free of centralization
and um really the worst case scenario
would be if we saw that history just
repeat itself exactly if we saw this
amazing decentralized distribution
method the most effective one ever
produced in the history of humanity if
we saw it captured by a handful of
centralized stakeholders and and them
controlling and surveilling the
communications that go through it
good things unlike processed cheese
never last
in an attempt to regulate yet another
slice of Our Lives legislative bills are
already in the works to try and control
the internet
but rather than wait for pesky red tape
like passing laws the government has
been proactive in trying to censor the
internet for our safety of course
for example with the help of their good
buddies and big Finance they were almost
able to shut down the controversial
website WikiLeaks
think what you will about Wikileaks the
point is that members of the government
were able to just speak with payment
processors and create this blockade and
say you cannot transfer money to this
organization and it's not much of a leap
to say wait hold on
the government or in some cases
companies can decide that nobody can do
business with these people or that
nobody can can see what these people are
publishing that's obviously a problem in
our in our tradition of free speech
Wikileaks was able to survive thanks
mostly to a very New Concept
decentralized money
unlike most currencies in the world
which are created and regulated by
central banks
decentralized currency such as Bitcoin
is created by the people and as such is
almost impossible to control
[Music]
bitcoin's a decentralized peer-to-peer
currency It's actually an Internet
Protocol kind of like uh SMTP that's how
you send emails well it's money over
Internet Protocol it's how we can send
money over the internet and we can use
it to transfer value without having a
middleman that means we don't need a
bank or a money transmitter between a
someone like Western Union we can just
send money like we send an email
Bitcoins I'm incredibly excited about it
because it's the first free market
private money that's also also a
technological money it's electronic
currency
the great thing about it is it's not
controlled by a central bank it's not
controlled by anyone it's actually
really the people's money so it gives a
lot of freedom
the supply of money and the cost of
money or interest rates set by some
bureaucrats 3 000 miles away in
Washington DC how efficient is that for
our economy because interest rates that
regulate production over time and they
regulate all the production within the
economy you know whether we should save
or whether we should build something
Bitcoin liberates that interest rate
because it's a censorship resistant
currency so we don't have to use their
money system anymore
decentralized currencies like Bitcoin
offer an alternative to the highly
regulated and controlled National
currencies of the world but as with the
government's push to regulate the
internet attempts to regulate the
purchase of Bitcoin have already been
seen
I recently tried to start up a Bitcoin
ATM I hired some lawyers in the U.S and
they told me you're under five different
Regulators in the U.S you're under
banking Finance money even
telecommunications because we're using
the internet and we looked into the
total cost just to start a Bitcoin ATM a
very basic product no less than 25
million dollars because we needed all
kinds of insurance bonds as a money
transmitter this is how they keep
competition out because they don't want
competition
these attempts to control increasing
amounts of our personal lives have some
people very concerned and with each
successive law or regulation the
temptation to opt out entirely becomes
more and more appealing
there are some people that are
abandoning ship they see the ship as
sinking they don't know whether it's
going to sink for sure or stay afloat
somehow they don't want to stay around
to find out they're just leaving while
the getting's good and I'm not going to
tell somebody not to leave because I
don't know for sure how bad it may or
may not get
Jeff Berwick is someone who has already
decided to opt out to this end he formed
an expat community in Chile hoping to
create a Haven for freedom-loving people
who can no longer tolerate the
government encroachment in their
personal affairs
we started this community because we've
really recognized that a lot of people
around the world want to get out of
these Western countries Rising taxation
Rising regulation people are getting put
in jail in the U.S all the time for
nothing victimless crimes people have
done nothing except for maybe drink raw
milk or have some plants in their pocket
called marijuana
[Music]
what we're trying to attract and what
we've been attracting is more
freedom-minded people
everyone has their own personal story
sometimes this is as simple as someone's
been pulled over like 10 times in a
month and been searched I've seen people
who have had their entire businesses
taken away through regulation and
fascism in the US there was one Doctor
Who Came Down recently he had a practice
in the U.S he had a almost 100 percent
cure cancer rate within one month and he
had about 30 SWAT team come in one day
and everything taken by the government
and so many people are just had enough
of being pushed around stolen beaten put
in cages for nothing to have most of
their money taken away and even
sometimes their entire livelihood taken
away
[Music]
can just pack up our lives and move to
Chile so what practical options are left
identifying the root of the problem is a
good place to start
the issue is there's this merger of what
would appear to be private Enterprise
and government and the only way to break
it is to restrict the power of the state
once you give the state the power
the authority over our lives in all
these areas
then there's no stopping it because then
the the individuals who are in those
fields are providing Medical Services
money monetary Services banking services
Power and Gas and Oil and all these
Services they will gravitate to the
government buy off the politicians make
the mergers pass the laws to their best
interest and the average you know the
gum chewing public thinks oh well isn't
that nice well what we voted for these
guys so I guess it's uh in our best
interests they don't get it
if you take all the temptation all the
power away from political office the
only people who will go into it will be
those who want to serve their country
because there's no way to steal anything
anymore
the only idea that I have as far as
trying to make government smaller is
that you in the United States we've got
the Constitution but every government
could pass some sort of amendment to
their constitution or whatever that says
that for every Law act code or
regulation that these Screwballs want to
pass that they've got to find two old
laws codes Acts or regulations that they
have to repeal that's one of the only
way that I can think of making
government smaller and the same thing
goes for all of the agencies if they
want to open up some other agency or
Department they've got to close to
individual freedom is what defines
Humanity although laws and regulations
can make us feel safe from the threats
we may face
all the safety in the world means
nothing without the freedom to live as
you choose
freedom is the most important
and indispensable characteristic of
mankind
we can be induced by promises from
government to depart from our Liberty
but there's nothing more profound for an
individual than when they are denied
something they very much need
because they made a decision earlier on
to part with their freedom and so when
you're terminally ill
and you suddenly discover that you can
only have access to FDA approved
treatments for your disease and you're
told by the doctors treating you that
there is no drug to treat your condition
and then to survive you're going to have
to find something else
and you discover that your desire and
your freedom of choice to attain that
end are blocked by the Food and Drug
Administration and so when you need your
freedom the most it's been taken away
from you
when you've been in a family that has
had a milk farm for 300 years or more
and suddenly federal agents come in and
they do a raid on your farm as if you
were a drug kingpin engaged in
international drug sales
and you're only selling milk
and then you realize your whole life has
been turned upside down
or you are a small businessman who
discovers that just to operate a gas
station you have to comply with EPA
regulations that will cost you more than
it will to run the gas station in profit
or you find out that you want to have a
food establishment a restaurant and you
discover that federal and state and
local regulations affecting your food
establishment are so great that you have
to have lawyers and you have to have
accountants and you have to have
individuals specially trained to comply
and you have to fill out all these forms
and you have to pay all these fees and
you have to get separate licenses
just to be in the business of reselling
food others have already manufactured
and put in the marketplace
it's the end of Liberty
foreign
how you regain freedom is is a huge
question
the individual knows that he's or she is
alive
the individual knows that he or she is
free to choose a future and a life
if they want
we either have free Societies or we
don't
there's such a thing as individual
Freedom where there isn't
that is the bottom line
if you want to live a life a real life
then Freedom must exist
so people have to step up to the plate
whenever they see individual Freedom
threatened along any channel
of human activity
that's where you start from
[Music]
when I was growing up New York was an
ugly ugly City where there was violence
in the streets all the time and the way
that they cleaned it up was by going and
getting people to go out and say no more
well that worked to stop the gangs the
same thing works when you get honest
people who engage in government and
maybe we can stop the government gangs
from sitting there and dictating the
terms of our lives and preventing us
from having the freedom and liberty
which we were guaranteed in an open
democracy
we are all individuals
we have the ability to think
to decide and most importantly to be
heard
[Music]
it may be time to start crying over
spilled milk
[Music]
I just built this this is not going to
be good
[Music]
boy I just saw those pictures of Kim
Kardashian pregnant I said man how could
a chick like that why does anybody want
to look at her you know
and yet she's a star well
[Music]
you don't want him in there
go down go downstairs there Geppetto no
I don't know where you can get anywhere
yet
that's a lie
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]